life is quick I'm sure all of you have
your lives planned out and the one thing
it can absolutely guarantee is it won't
work out that way I accept the world as
it is and I go forward if you don't have
passion for your work or the drive to
make a better life for your kids in your
own then you won't have what it takes to
keep you going you're going to have to
be you know flexible and nimble in your
life you don't you don't buy a thick
skin and you don't even know you have it
until somebody starts to try to puncture
it most of the books I've read didn't
apply directly to my job or industry but
I've applied their lessons in unexpected
ways you also have to peek at the time
it's an Olympic year you know you could
be the fastest runner in the world and
it's an off year being successful in
business means part of it is trying to
guess what's going to happen part of it
is trying to guess the future I came
home and told my wife I was quitting and
she cried the people we get a kind of
person at Goldman Sachs who really wants
to be an influential person he's an
American business executive he's the CEO
and chairman of Goldman Sachs he's one
of the highest-paid executives on Wall
Street
he's Lloyd Blankfein and here his top
ten rules for success life is quick I'm
sure all of you have your lives planned
out and the one thing it can absolutely
guarantee is it won't work out that way
because it just things happen first of
all the world changes and the world
evolved so whatever plans you're making
it's based on a static world that won't
be there because things will happen and
you'll change or maybe you won't even
change maybe you just miss identifying
yourself now you don't know which is a
perfectly appropriate way to be when you
know you're young or my age cuz you know
who knows so what would you change about
the way that you ended up as a CEO of
Goldman Sachs
you know I don't have that you know how
the mayor just said you know he looks
forward maybe the next day isn't me
better I and I think a corollary of that
is I don't I don't really ii i don't
look i I accept the world as it is and I
go forward I mean I you know I could do
an archeological dig but I can't go back
and change it so I don't spend a lot of
time fussing about
when you learn I want to learn from it
but I don't want to wring my hands and
recriminate so it's never you know I
wish I would taller wish I could run
faster
I got a lower hand again wish I had a
lower hand again I have plenty of
handicap but not in but not the low one
in golf that I want but I don't spend a
lot of time thinking about that but if
you put me to it I'll tell you another
thing that anybody who had a chance to
revisit the past with what he knows now
we'd be crazy not to do it but it's just
not available so how much time you spend
on it in my career I've been fortunate
to know and work with many of this
country's top CEOs and business leaders
I'm always struck by a certain passion
that defines them while they may be
wealthy and powerful their passion goes
beyond money and power I won't stand
here and tell you that those are bad
things they're pretty good but only if
you have a larger purpose in mind if you
don't have passion for your work or the
drive to make a better life for your
kids than your own then you won't have
what it takes to keep you going you're
going to have to be you know flexible
and nimble in your life that's the
that's the characteristic you want to
get you don't it's not important whether
you know what the product is of the
shore or what's hot and what's not or
how to execute this particular thing you
need to learn business and you need to
learn how to question and have an open
mind you need to know the process of
thinking about things you notice how
people can go around and be an investor
in this industry turn around without
doing anything being a great investor in
another industry or some CEO one day is
running Ford Motor Company then can run
Boeing or different industries because
it's not the the most important thing is
not the particular characteristics of
the particular industry or thing it's
how to be a good CEO just like it's how
to be a present Kataeb presentation
skills how to be a good manager how to
be a good subordinate how to be a good
partner how to use people how to be
usable by people how you know and those
are the things
that you have to learn now you can only
learn it you can't learn it abstractly
you can't really learn it in school you
have to learn it by doing but you have
to take those lessons and extrapolate it
so you know the things that I did in the
markets you know the markets that and
the context of even in investment
banking advisory those are highly
different things thirty years ago than
they are today they're different five
years ago than they are today
so everything is oh you know we talk
about time of great change yeah you know
okay every time is a time of great
change and I will tell you and the
technology is driving it you know we and
you don't know everybody always
remembers getting it right when they
thought forward because you always
acquire after quired
information always affects your views
you don't remember what you used to
think and so that's just the nature of
things and the people who be successful
in their lives are the people who are
the most flexible who can absorb the
most who are open to learn and learn who
are coachable who are not too proud to
you know dig in to new things who is an
entrepreneur where everything is a
smooth ride and you go through these
things and I'll tell you and you get
criticized and you have to have a thick
skin yeah yeah and you've been there
I've been there and and by the way you
don't you don't buy a thick skin and you
don't even know you have it until
somebody starts to try to puncture it
and then you discover what you're made
of
to be a well rounded complete person
many of you will go for further
education or career training of course
it's important to learn the things that
you need to make a living but don't
forget to read and to learn history
literature and about current events
you'll be more interesting to others
more interesting to yourself and you'll
be more successful in your job most of
the books I've read didn't apply
directly to my job or industry but I've
applied their lessons in unexpected ways
if you're an Olympic athlete or
something light you get to the high you
also have to peek at the time it's an
Olympic year now you could be the
fastest runner in the world and it's an
off year and so you know by the time you
get to the Olympics three years later
you know you
anymore so there's a lot of luck
involved in things in the world I'll
ever live my life thinking about my next
job because I was always in the last job
I could have as far as I could tell and
I think it's a huge advantage for you to
live in the moment and not to be
seething too much I mean obviously you
plan even though your plans never work
out but to if you want you know the
secret is to do a great job with what
you're doing and you know what you
should do is you should perform as if
you were in your next job but not seed
with the ambition to get there
and project that you'll make people
nervous as hell and you kill yourself I
give you an example you know when I was
in high school you know I went to you
know because you heard all those
advisory boards I was it went to Harvard
College at Harvard you know law school
now when I went to the college from the
high school I came from I never dawned
on me that I'd get into that kind of an
Ivy League's it just wasn't just didn't
happen but I applied and I never thought
about it after really I applied because
it just wasn't like it wasn't on my
scope and so when I got a letter that I
got I didn't have any anxiety to it and
when I got that letter I just was like
you know ecstatic and I this and then my
mind opened up but it was just like a
great experience of that was great when
I was in college and I applied to law
school I went down to the mailbox every
day I knew the consequences of it I was
with a bunch of people who also wanted
it and were vying for it and I was like
torturing myself over and I was
imagining what if I do get it what if I
don't get it what are the consequence of
getting in or not and I tell you I you
know it affected my life in affected you
know you know you know the functionality
that's a difference I tell you if you
could approach every opportunity like I
did the college one you'll be better and
you'll you'll be happier and if you live
the life tormented about what are my
prospects for the next one
when life is random and you have to be
you know and there's some chance
involved in things you're going to be
tortured being successful in business
means part of it is trying to guess
what's going to happen
part of it is trying to guess the future
history is as important as economics
okay right in other words being able to
see gee this period of time it's not the
same as the 1980s but it's like it I
remember another time when politics were
poisoned or this or that or this
situation in the world today or the
conflict we're seeing in the Middle East
how does that how was that in the
temperament of the times and the
reaction that produces compared to the
period of time when everybody worried
about the rise of Russia or the rise of
what's that like what it in other words
nothing is new and you know everything
of course is different but the cycles
repeat and I think the study of history
gives you a feeling knowing that nothing
stays the same and everything is evolved
nothing is static that's an important
lesson to learn if I want to be good in
economics I'd want to know economic
history if I want to be a good scientist
I'd want to know the history of science
and that would maybe help me understand
the receptive receptivity of the world
to advances today and why some things
get accepted and why some things don't
and yeah I thought so and so that's uh
you know anyway that's just my prejudice
and my background has made me appreciate
knowing the history of things and not
just the science of things after college
I went to law school for three years and
then into my dream job at a big New York
law firm but even though it had been my
dream I didn't like it once I got there
for the first time I was feeling
financially secure but I knew I wasn't
passionate enough about what I was doing
and because I didn't love it I would
never be fulfilled from it or be really
good at it
someone who loved it more would have
greater enthusiasm and focus for some it
was fun for me it was always going to be
a horrible chore after five years at a
law firm I decided I wanted to try
something different I came home and told
my wife I was quitting and she cried
and not out of happiness anyway it
worked out I got a new job at a small
Wall Street firm having been rejected at
every other one we got out by a larger
firm and I ended up remaining at that
large firm Goldman Sachs you're the
question why do you think Goldman Sachs
does better than everybody else I'll do
what I assume yeah I assume you hire the
best people because we recruit and hire
the best people and more importantly
because we retain them and the reason
why we retain them and the reason why we
get the best people is and I believe
this which are Seagal let me say yeah oh
just let me let me say this because we
get people who are really interested in
doing something that they think is good
for the for the public for the world
there and if you look at you mentioned
earlier my predecessors who became
secretaries of treasure I could take you
back and give you a hundred and the
people we get a kind of person at
Goldman Sachs who really wants to be an
influential person who wants to do
something that's important feels that a
lot of money and then go out and do good
you know something the people that we
have don't would like to do well for
themselves also do I most of them at the
height of their careers go into public
service I mean that record is your
regular time not just in the US but all
around the world not just at the top of
the firm but in the middle of the firm
so you're saying the secretive Goldman
Sachs is that they hire the right people
and we hired right we hire the right
people okay and retain the right people
and at certain times lose the right
people and make room for other right
people to come in thank you so much for
watching I made this video because
Martell Thomas asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you I made a
profile next leave it in the comments
below I don't see what I can do I'd also
love
which of the top ten rules today hit you
the hardest meant the most to you leave
in comments and I'll join the discussion
and my personal goal on this channel is
to hit 1 million subscribers so anything
you can think of to help share the video
spread the message tweet it at the
playlist I really really appreciate it
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon